good morning Hank it's Friday I didn't
sleep much last night so if it's okay
with you let's meet on the floor oh
that's better Hank Here I am nestled
among author copies of my books in
foreign languages like this is Looking
for Alaska in Japanese right to ink but
anyway this week we've been discussing
ultimate concerns and I've been
fascinated to read thousands of comments
from nerdfighters talking about what
they think their ultimate concerns are
or whether they think they should have
an ultimate concern or whether there
should be a single priority that is
prioritized above all others la fest
cached the Margeaux I think that means
the the funny face of Margot I got a 1
on the French AP exam I did think it was
interesting that you said that you would
die and fight to recreate the Library of
Alexandria which by the way is a great
idea if only we could die or fight to
make that happen I think your point
about the Library of Alexandria though
is exactly why it's useful to think
about ultimate concerns it's because it
tells you what you value you would die
to recreate the Library of Alexandria
because you value knowledge and
information and the availability of
information to all here's something
that's weird Hank the German covers of
my books always have feet on them
Looking for Alaska feet an abundance of
katherines feet lagos Putin feet girl
feet this time but still feet a lot of
nerdfighters in comment said that their
ultimate concern with saving lives or
preserving life or preserving quality of
life in other people that sort of the
utilitarian worldview and we often hear
that the role of people in other
people's lives should be to create the
greatest good for the greatest number of
humans which is a totally legitimate
value system except that none of us
actually lives by it in Serbian my name
is Dijon grin the thing I think if you
truly feel like your life is no more
valuable than the lives of others there
are lots of things that you can
sacrifice in order to improve the lives
of others here's an example of our kind
of universal failure to be truly
utilitarian people traditionally give
much more money to fight diseases that
their friends and family get then they
give to fight diseases that are the
biggest public health threats like for
example because breast cancer is a maid
of suck disease that attacks one of my
very favorite organs of ladies and has
also affected several members of my
family I give money to breast cancer
research and I'm statistically more
likely to give money to fight breast
cancer than I am to say fighting cholera
even though cholera is a bigger public
health crisis that kills more people
younger
hello big eyed Italian girl Henk quoted
on the back of the Italian edition of
Looking for Alaska is one of the most
popular quotes from the novel imaginary
el futuro saw detorri bunny I don't
speak Italian imagining the future is a
kind of nostalgia and the great thing
about that quote is that I didn't think
it up it was said to me by Sarah on our
first date we were sitting across the
table from each other at the sandwich
shop and she said imagining the future
is a kind of nostalgia and I said oh I
must marry you so I think we all end up
printing those who are close to us over
those who aren't but I think we also end
up privileges the threats that are close
to us over the threats that aren't which
is why Hank I'm so impressed by your
farsighted ultimate concern this is the
Mexican edition of Looking for Alaska
and I think it's my favorite one because
it's got this labyrinth in the a and
then the inexplicable shoe Oh
inexplicable shoe you're probably a
metaphor but I don't understand you Hank
there's this great Nigerian writer who
once said you can make your children
safe in the world or you can try to make
a world safe for children and what I've
enjoyed so much about this week's
conversation between you and me and
among all of nerdfighteria is talking
about how we are going to strike that
balance between making us feel safe in
the world and trying to make a world
that's safe for all I'll see you on
Monday
hey Hank did you know that I can speak
Polish buzu ja c whoa
BOSU 21 we a coup in Polish Schenk that
means this book is better than 21
regular books